Heute startet in bangkok die
un-klimakonferenz zur vorbereitung des weltklimagipfels im polnischen kattowitz im dezember dabei herrscht in thailand alarmstimmung
der vorsitzende der konferenz fidschis ministerpräsident frank bainimarama
kritisiert dass dem pariser klimaabkommen keine taten gefolgt sind ist die klimakatastrophe noch aufzuhalten klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Heute ist quasi
weltklima tag hier bei pixum heute abend um 18 uhr unser klima stream zu dem ich mich sehr freue marcel von den
attentätern dabei zu haben und um 1730 der livestream schon
hierfür kanal mitglieder und patterns in den streams habe ich übrigens eine brandaktuelle
und ausnahmsweise mal positive nachricht für euch seid gespannt und unser video heute zum klimawandel was ist also los nichts
muss man provozieren zusammenfassen der klimaschutz kommt einfach nicht voran wenn es so weitergeht dann
klima wandeln wir unseren blauen planeten so dass er eben nicht mehr blau ist sondern
verdorrt und die menschheit das nicht überleben wird einen vorgeschmack gab es schon jetzt so sei deutschland von oben aus jetzt im sommer nachdem
alexander gerst in der internationalen raumstation iss einige wochen immer nachts über deutschland geflogen war machte er am 6 august
diese aufnahmen gas dazu
schockierender anblick alles vertrocknet und braun was eigentlich grün sein sollte und das betrifft in diesem sommer die komplette
nordhalbkugel zum ersten mal seitdem wir das wetter beobachten war die gesamte nordhalbkugel in einem sommer heiß
zitat
davon sind wir alle
überrascht worden und wir können derzeit nicht sagen ob das ein phänomen ist dass wir häufiger erwarten müssen aber das heißt nicht dass es nicht
passiert nur dass wir es noch nicht wissenschaftlich belegen können so anders levermann vom potsdam institut für klimafolgenforschung
doch zum ersten mal lehnt sich ein klimaforscher extrem aus dem fenster motiv latif einer der
führenden wissenschaftler auf dem gebiet des klimawandels in deutschland bisher war immer extrem
zurückhaltend und mit konkrete bezüge zwischen wetter und klima selbst im letzten jahr als der durch den klimawandel
verlangsamt jak si mit einer rost die welle die dadurch stärker in den süden reichen einen unwetter nach deutschland katapultierte
vermied es latif einen konkreten zusammenhang herzustellen und
ja das ist wissenschaftlich absolut korrekt denn das konkret diese roski welle durch den klimawandel
verursacht wurde das kann niemand konkret nachweisen wobei der zusammenhang schon ziemlich deutlich ist aber latif ist
wissenschaftler ganz klar doch jetzt attraktiv seine zurückhaltung aufgegeben die hitze in diesem sommer findet latif zitat
außergewöhnlich weil sie schon so lange anhält es bestätige sich mehr und mehr was wir klimaforscher lange
vorausgesagt haben und das in bezug auf den klimawandel in deutschland so der professor am kieler helmholtz-zentrum für ozeanforschung
zur passauer neuen presse
wetter und klimawandel
lassen sich also immer konkreter in einen zusammenhang bringen und die politik versagt wir haben ja gerade
über eine von greenpeace beauftragte studie des fraunhofer instituts für energiewirtschaft und
energiesystemtechnik berichtet these deutschland kann seine klimaziele noch locker erreichen wenn kohlekraftwerke
abgeschaltet oder gedrosselt werden und das ohne gefährdung der versorgungssicherheit
aber die politik tut einfach nichts es ist wirklich hochnotpeinlich wenn brandenburgs
ministerpräsident dietmar woidke von der spd warnt zitat ein schneller kohleausstieg
stärkt die afd dann zeigt er damit nur eins er ist kein politiker
überspitzt formuliert er nimmt also die vernichtung der menschheit in kauf damit die afg nicht stärker wird das ist aber sein
verdammter job als politiker das zu verhindern was sind das für lappen bei den etablierten parteien angela merkel hat vor der letzten bundestagswahl
ihr versprechen dazu gegeben zitat wir werden wege finden wie wir ist 2020 unser 40 ziel einhalten
das verspreche ich ihnen ja scheint sie jetzt nicht mehr sonderlich zu interessieren denn von diesem klimaziel sind wir meilenweit
entfernt macht also mit und unterzeichnet die petition bei change.org und hier geht es wirklich nicht um irgendeine politische
entscheidung oder meinung ich denke dass linke wie rechte und alle dazwischen die zukunft der menschheit retten wollen es geht nur um eins kann ich
logisch denken verstehe das prinzip von wissenschaft und damit die klimaforschung oder habe ich in der schule nicht richtig aufgepasst und vertraut
verschwörungstheorien erstere also einfach hier draufklicken und wenn ihr den klima stream heute nicht verpassen wollt dann ist hier der link dazu
mitglieder und patterns bekommen zu ihrem stream noch eine extra nachricht mehr collection gibt's heute nicht bis dann
bleibt dran